i'm greg jarbo and i'm the content
marketing faculty chair at market motive
and what is that i mean what we're going
to talk about in this first module
of a content marketing foundation course
is liberally content marketing um
okay what is it
so content marketing is not a new
concept it's been around for over a
hundred years in fact one of the classic
foundation stories of you know the birth
of content marketing goes all the way
back to the michelin brothers in france
and the michelin brothers you know in
case you haven't done your history
that's okay you know a little refresher
right now
were two brothers who made pneumatic
tires
and they were trying to sell them along
with an innovative product at its time
called the automobile
in an era where the roads were horrible
in a place france
where frankly people didn't like to get
outside of paris and into the provinces
because my god what was worth going out
there for
you know
are paris that's all happening here
and what the michelin brothers realized
is if they wanted to sell more tires
they had to get people to drive farther
and farther
and use them
so what did they come up with
the concept that really is the birth of
content marketing in my book
was the michelin guide
and the michelin guide was unique in
that it reviewed
restaurants
not just restaurants nearby in paris but
restaurants out there
in the provinces
and the michelin brothers are the ones
who came up with the one two and three
star rating system to say this
restaurant i know it's way out there
it's you know bad roads uh but guess
what to die for the ratatouille ah you
you gotta have it this is a three-star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip
and oh by the way now since we're going
to give you a guide
and you have to get out of paris in
order to get there we're going to tell
you where you can find gasoline along
the way
which hotels you might want to stay at
overnight and oh by the way just in case
you have to
how to repair a flat tire particularly
if it's a michelin tire because it's a
pneumatic and you know what it's quite
easy to repair
and guess what that put michelin on the
map why they weren't trying to sell you
more tires
they weren't telling you about the
features and benefits of round
or
tire repair i mean that was in there but
it was only a how-to article not
necessarily a feature and benefit
what they were doing was they were
speaking to their audience about what
their audience was truly passionate
about which in
paris in 1900
was food
and by creating content
that got the audience to get into their
new innovative automobile
and drive all the way out there into the
provinces for that absolutely remarkable
three-star restaurant
people got more flats
people had to replace their tires
but it was worth it
and oh by the way
michelin sold more tires
so that
that's a great story every time you sort
of
you know hit a pause and like well we're
doing content marketing we need to come
up with a concept
thank you back to the michelin guide
it's
it's great foundation
so let's go
to a modern definition where are we now
in the 21st century
when it comes to content marketing
well you can read the slide here and
read the definition and some people like
reading definitions i'm not going to
read it to you but i am going to
highlight a couple of words in the
definition that i think are absolutely
critical to any definition
of content marketing
the content that you create needs to be
relevant
and it also has to be
valuable
now if it's not relevant
then you're not actually meeting my
needs or interests
you know and why would i be interested
and we've gotten way too tired
of screening out the commercial that
comes on
um you know trying to sell us snow tires
and pardon me we live in florida
i don't use snow tires what the what the
heck is this commercial doing
you know interrupting what i'm watching
so relevance is important
relevance means that this content isn't
going to get screened out
and the valuable the valuable can can
work in a lot of different ways it can
be interesting
it can be useful
you know value
is an interesting proposition all by
itself
but that's the key to content marketing
uh it's not just creating more spam
it's not just throwing more trash over
the fence and hoping something happens
this is something where if you've
created valuable and relevant content
you know what your customers will find
you
that's a whole different kind of
proposition
i know there's some skeptics saying oh
come on come on come on content
marketing is just a fancy new name
for social media marketing right and the
answer is well there is some overlap and
we're going to deal with that in module
three
but let me just be clear here
social media content
is part of what content marketing needs
to create
but it can also create content for your
website
and that's not the social media it can
also create content that
your pr people can share with
reporters or bloggers and that's not
normally considered
social media content
and by the way
all of that content can be optimized so
maybe it actually is part of
seo not social media marketing in fact
that's the other place that content
marketing really overlaps
and it's not coincidental
it so happens that around february
2011 when google rolled out the first of
its
multiple versions of the panda update
all of a sudden even seos
started to pay attention to content
marketing why
because google changed the rules and
what google basically said is if your
content isn't valuable or relevant
you know what it's not going to rank
very well in our search algorithm
and all of a sudden people who had been
used to like putting keywords in the
right places
realized content matters you mean i've
got to actually tell stories that are
interesting i've got to
create information that's valuable
yeah you can make it relevant that's the
optimization part
but you know if you're trying to
optimize a piece of boring irrelevant
trash
god bless you good luck
so yeah content marketing
has grown it's like tripled
in terms of web search interest since
the panda update
and then we're talking about panda one
of course there was panda two panda
three panda four i mean come on
google is driving us in this direction
and so content marketing is pretty
relevant today
now one of the other things that uh
people in content marketing struggle
with is oh but you don't understand i do
b2b content marketing or i'm a small
business or part me i'm an enterprise
and so content marketing has to come in
flavors right
well possibly
maybe
on occasion
so let's just question that assumption
for a second
you know
content marketing has been around now
long enough and enough people have done
it that some research has been conducted
and has been conducted against b2c
marketers and b2b marketers and small
business marketers and enterprise level
marketers
and when they start asking key questions
like okay
we're going to try to determine what is
the difference between an effective
content marketer and an ineffective
content marketer
let's see the results
well
first of all
the most important thing to be an
effective b2c
content
marketer is you need a documented
content strategy
okay all right i mean people who are
winging it aren't as
effective as people who actually have
thought about this uh written it down
got it okay
no great insight but you know
interesting to note
secondly they've got to have somebody in
charge who oversees content marketing
oh lord does that mean we have to have a
reorg or maybe we just have to designate
somebody who reports to somebody else
whatever but guess what
it really helps if somebody is driving
this process
third they've got to be using more
content marketing tactics
than their less effective peers
and this is not an argument more is
better this is just pardon me that's the
way the data falls out the people who
are
actually more effective
are doing more different kinds of things
a broader range of tactics
and who knows maybe it's that broader
range that's part of the success formula
same thing is true with social media
platforms
the effective content marketers are
using more than the ineffective ones
and last but not least and this may be a
sort of a result of the first four
by gosh
effective content marketers
generally have
greater percentage
of the overall marketing budget in their
organization
wow okay
that's the b2c marketing forum but you
don't understand i'm not a b2c marketer
okay
so let's take a look at the b2b content
marketing formula
guess what
you need to have a documented content
marketing strategy to be an effective
b2b content marketer you need to have
someone who oversees content marketing
strategy
it helps if you are using more
tactics
and more social media platforms
and guess what you spend a higher
percentage of your overall marketing
budget
on content marketing well that's similar
to the b2c content marketers but you
understand b2b is different yeah there's
a couple small differences but guess
what overall the top five criteria
are similar
and when you get to small business
here's what you're going to see
same five criteria
and you're in an enterprise i know the
world is different for enterprises
actually not so much
so four different data points let's net
it out ah there's a pattern
and the pattern is is i don't care what
flavor of content marketer you are
you can be b to c b to b you can be
small business you can be large
enterprise
at the end of the day there are five
things that you've got to focus on
if you want to be effective we've
already covered these and are there
differences between small businesses and
large enterprises between b2b and b2c
well sure
but they're all at the margin
what's the downside if we don't do this
you know is anyone going to come in and
like whack us
and the answer is um
maybe not inside your boardroom
but it may happen on the next sales call
that one of your sales people makes
they may encounter someone i like to
call the man in the chair
and the man on the chair actually refers
back to a classic mcgraw-hill ad
campaign from i think the 1960s
but basically the guy in the chair asks
theoretically some questions from quote
maybe your sales person okay
i don't know anything about you i don't
know about your company i don't know
about your company's product i don't
know about your company's you know
reputation
or anything about you and so what was it
you were going to try to sell me
and that's the downside of not
having
a content
marketing program
we've actually found in work that we've
done with companies
that content marketing can shorten
the sales cycle why you're providing
people with information at key points
that they need in order to take the next
step
so yeah is there a downside sure stick
with the status quo
struggle
swimming against the tide
you know what
it's probably smarter to have a content
marketing program
so this introductory module in the
content marketing foundation
try to ask
and answer these questions what is
content marketing
and oh by the way just how different are
b2c b2b
small business
and enterprise content marketing
and i think you've got the answer
content marketing
means that your content
needs to be relevant
and it needs to be valuable
and by the way that content can come in
a whole lot of different forms it's not
just words on paper it can be videos
it could be infographics it can be
webinars it can be speeches that your
executives are giving in public you know
content can take a lot of different
forms but at the end of the day
you want to be an effective
content marketer
and for that we're going to go through
five more modules
and let me give you sort of a highlight
of what we're going to cover
guess what we're going to cover all the
things that makes you effective we're
going to cover content marketing
strategy you need a documented one
so we'll go through that and by the way
we're going to have a little extra bonus
because it's a problem that we've seen
people encounter again and again which
is all right before we've ever done this
in my organization i need to get a
budget for like a pilot project how do i
do that what do i do when i don't have a
budget i'm trying to start up content
marketing in my organization so that's
gonna be covered in module two module
three we're going to talk about someone
who oversees content marketing yeah
right the org chart
and what we're really going to focus in
then this happens more in larger
enterprise than other organizations but
even smaller businesses someday aspire
to be medium-sized businesses and many
even sized businesses want to grow up to
be large enterprises so you know what
it's probably useful for all of us to
understand where this is headed
and we'll talk about the lack of
integration
across the marketing mix
both within the organization but also
outside when it comes to communicating
to customers and why
guess what
maybe it's time to organize a little
differently third
we'll talk about all those content
marketing tactics and instead of just
listing them all because you know what
lists
are interesting but they're not
persuasive
what we're going to look at are the
content marketing tactics
that content marketers consider
most effective
so that windows down the list
and you're going to want to take some
time and learn not just
the broad range of things you could be
doing
but the ones that seem to move the
needle
and then
then we'll tackle the sort of subsidiary
question
of how do i produce a variety of content
you know that seems to be a problem for
some folks
well trust me once you get your handle
uh your arms around
the whole
what is effective the variety of content
pretty much takes care of itself
in the fifth module we're going to take
a look at social media platforms and
again
content marketers are experimenting with
a wide variety of them
the list seems to change daily as new
ones are introduced
or suddenly the the list is revised
because uh some social media platform
just got acquired but now the company
that acquired it is you know
pretty big and pretty interesting so
maybe we need to pay attention to that
too well guess what once again
we're going to do a little triage here
we're only going to look at the ones
that seem to be most effective today
and you too may want to experiment with
other ones beyond that what it helps to
have as a core part of your content
marketing programs the ones that are the
most effective
and then guess what the challenge
is not having one
the challenge is actually producing
engaging content for those social media
platforms so we'll look at that in
module five and in module six
we're going to talk about budgets why
because it all comes down to the budget
you got to have one and by the way you
need to be spending a larger
percentage of your marketing budget on
content marketing in order to be
effective
in order to do that we're going to have
to skim this cat we're going to have to
look at
measurement
we're going to have to
get you over the hurdle of how come it
is so hard to measure the effectiveness
of my content
you know how do i know that when
when can i turn around and show that to
the top management so they can say wow
that moved the needle fine
you need a bigger budget next year
you've got it
so
that's what's coming um
stay tuned uh strap in this is
gonna be a bumpy ride at times but guess
what
it is a journey worth taking